Hello everybody, my name is markiplier and welcome back to universe sandbox now
I haven't played this game since the oh, it's so cool song came out
I've only played it once and I think that's actually a tragedy because I I recently came across some videos of this again
I was like, oh man, I
Really think this game is cool. Like this game is just kind of alright, whoa. Hey, whoa
Ease up there Sonny Boy. (Nice pun) Wow, there's so much detail on that
Look at that.
I didn't know the hell was there before though the squiggles in the Sun so it's been a while since I played it again. And uh
Yeah, I thought I'd just give it another go and I wanted to do this a bit more objective-based.
Oh my god
That as far as it goes? Oh boy
Whoa, ah man this thing still blows my mind
I mean, it's it's it's just like it's not that crazy, but it's kind of crazy
Okay
so there's a few things that I wanted to do when I played this again the last time I played this I didn't really have
An objective this time
I want to
Recreate a few events and also create some events that are from questions that I would have and I would kind of like to see
Reproduce in a way that is less destructive to our solar system and leads to us all being dead. Oh, man
Look at all these objects, you know for the first time in a long time
I went out to Hawaii for my vacation. I could see the center of the Milky Way (What?!?) like I could actually see it
it's something if the night is clear enough and you don't have as much light pollution and some people around the world like this is
A common thing, but if you look up at the sky you can actually see the center of the galaxy
This is such a fascinating concept and and I haven't seen it since I was a kid
just because it's been so like light pollution in LA and stuff like that, but you can lose sight of this beautiful like
magnificent awe-inspiring sight
That's just available for everybody to see up in the night sky. The sheer magnitude of that center of the galaxy,
It-It- not even comparing to the rest of the universe like the sheer magnitude of that center of the galaxy, just that milky arm
spreading across the sky is,
(A deep breath of space love)
So,
Immensely huge that you cannot perceive it. Like the magnitude of it is something that your brain tries to process,
but it just does not go anywhere near the truth of
How tiny we are in comparison to that object, and it's not even an object
It's a collection of objects, and then beyond that it's just one galaxy in a universe of billions of galaxies,
But I could see that and it kind of got me thinking like ay I want to play this again
So here I am ready to play it again,
and so what I want to do like in the beginning here, what I really really want to do is
I want to
Reverse time. Okay. We're gonna go back in time. We're gonna go back in time really far. Okay
so what I'm doing right now is I'm sending the
solar system into a spiral of death
What we have here is a simulation that's running faster than it can mathematically
Collate so what's gonna happen eventually is this is going to get so
unbelievably wonky as
It starts to lose its position that things are going to drift farther and farther of where they actually would be in an accurate simulation
And we're just going to eventually fall apart. You can see like this this actual target is much lower than what it should be
I'm aiming I'm aiming for
Yeah, a hundred and forty-five thousand years per second, but I think that's that's a little bit too much
Let's let's get like I want I want to hit a nice nine hundred years per second
That's what I that's what I would be going for. I mean, this is blazing through it's now
1885 but I want to go farther
I want to go all the way back to the beginning and the only way to do that is to sacrifice some accuracy
Otherwise, I'm gonna be here forever. So I'm going to increase the max positional error to let's make it a good old 10 meters per second
That's how bad the positional can be. So let's keep it going
Oh
Now what's interesting is this movement here that's actually the movement of the Sun through the galaxy
See the sun's not just in one spot. It's moving
We all are I mean not just around the Sun but our entire solar system is moving
Around the galaxy in a big spiral as the Milky Way twists and turns so do we twist and turn upon it
Among the billions and billions of stars that we exist on
but this is still not going fast enough
i want faster. I want lots of faster
All right, there we go now we're picking up some speed. Oh my god, that is not right. Oh
We're getting into some kind of a spiral but we're moving faster now a little bit faster. But uh, you know, it's uh,
It is what it is. So let's add another zero to this bad boy
No, not there on that side of the decimal doesn't work anything. Okay?
Whoa, whoa. Oh, we are booking it back in time. All right, we are gunning
We're gunning back in time way wickedly way way way fast. So I'm gonna pause this boink and
Where are we exactly what what? Oh, what is uh, what is the current situation that's going on here?
We've got a whole lot of nothing. Let's let's tune it down. Let's go back to one year a second
Let's try to make this a little less crazy. You know, I don't even know where earth is here
Where's earth? Did we lose earth there's earth Okay, I think we might have lost earth. Oh my god. We lost earth
Oh no earth. Wait, um
earth baby listen, listen, uh, whoa
Earth there. You are. Okay Earth
okay, you're being real optimistic saying that it is zero zero zero zero eighty and there's
Life on this planet with lights and whatnot. But you know, let's let's let's assume that you're just being optimistic here
okay, so we've officially destroyed the entirety of
Everything we have reversed time into the point where everything exploded. Yeah. It's no good
so one of the things that I wanted to explore was this topic that
there could be a
moment where earth
just simply
loses it like if the Sun were to disappear, okay, if for whatever reasons say a
Black hole or another star passed close enough by our solar system to pull
The earth out of orbit or if the Sun were to suddenly disappear
Completely all of the planets would just like go off
Instantaneously tangential to where they were originally going with nothing left to pull them down into the gravity
Well, the Sun nothing's gonna hold them in orbit anymore. Therefore they instantaneously just carry on the way they were going
So what I want to do now is I want to show you
Let's how do we reset this whole shebang? All right. So here we have the solar system it is
Home the only home we'd ever know and the only home that we got right now what's gonna happen if I just you know?
Get rid of the Sun
If say for example the Sun
just
pause
disappear
What would happen?
There they go
all the planets all the orbiting objects everything that once was is
Now gone off on its own Jupiter's going off on its own
All of the asteroids are going off their own Uranus is off on its own as we all know
Neptune even Pluto gone off into the cold dark depths of forever now that we're at this point
It's a little too late. But what if we were to suddenly bring the Sun back, let's say the sun's gonna go right
Try to get it exactly where it was poink and there she is oh
Whoops there she goes oopsies. Ah, wait. Oh
No, that's two suns now. That's not what I wanted. Okay, that is just ri-god-damn-diculous. Can you?
Okay, now we got two suns in an orbit
All right, not what I was hoping for but hey, you know, I'm not complaining that is a pretty sweet ballet
Okay
So we got two balleting Suns here going off in a spiral and you can see
That the other objects in the solar system are suddenly
Starting to be pulled back not all of them. Earth seems to be pretty well off on its own
It might have a slight curve towards yeah
It's got a slight curve, but I don't think it's ever gonna return back, but you never know
Let's see what happens Jupiter has made quite the turn
Yeah, Jupiter seems to be coming back. The Sun is desperately trying to orbit
the other Sun Hebe is caught up in the dance real hardcore earth is still projected to
Dance out that way for almost all eternity
But oh my god
You can see its projected line just with the dancing of the suns it doesn't know what it's gonna be doing. That's funny
Gonna add more Suns to this. Okay, let's add another Sun there. Oh
Whoa. Okay. Wait. No, it's not good. I just blew up everything. Holy shit. Oh
Shit okay. Well supernova aside Wow. Oh oh, oh
God okay that that was a bigger boom than I thought it was gonna be
Okay. All right. Okay. All right. Okay. That's that's not good. All right. Okay. Let's reset for a second. All right
Now I know what I'm gonna be doing. I have a good idea
so what I'm gonna be doing
The most fascinating thing that I see yeah besides blowing up the entirety of the Sun
That's fun and all but I want to go through as many ways as possible of destroying
The earth our home the only home that we have and what worse fate could befall it than to be
Subjected to the forces of the cruel cruel universe of which we live in it's not gonna be fun. It's not gonna be pretty
But it's going to be what we do here. So I want to focus on just
old-fashioned Earth
removing all the other variables
I mean in this one, we're gonna obviously like we're not gonna be doing much but it's just earth earth, and it's lonely moon
Let's imagine a few scenarios. All right, everyone put your thinking caps on so imagine Earth is here, right?
it's fine, but I think one of the nightmare scenarios, is that the moon would eventually just
Fall into earth one way I can do that is actually just by making earth
Way heavier. It's this looks Oh
Shirt Oh, goodbye. What the hell happened?
Fragment, did you scrape the earth Oh
that was a bit too fast. Hang on wait. I didn't even see it. What the hell happened. All right. Go again. Oh
Is that oh well
incoming i guess
That that looks like one of my Kerbal space program
trajectories gone horribly wrong
Woosh. Okay. Yep. This one is not gonna go farther
It's gonna be in a decaying orbit until it eventually just slams into this thing. Oh,
The fragments. Oh my god. The gravity of Earth is ripping the moon apart. That's so cool
The moon is literally being torn to shreds which is probably bad because these fragments are probably gonna be slamming into Earth
in no time flat, but
besides that let's
Focus on the here snd the now. Oh my god, there's so many fragments
Either way, this is not spelling good stuff for the earth. The earth is in a lot of trouble and oh here comes
Oh my god
The moon has an evil glowing eye
Staring death right at the earth oh my god, there fragments get pulled
Right off of the moon
There's a reason oh, look at the shadow. Oh, that's cool
Yeah, so that's what happens with like Saturn's rings. There's a certain zone inside Saturn's gravity well
Where objects orbiting it cannot stay in one piece
they cannot collate into an object because their gravity is not strong enough to fight against the forces of
like the orbital like
Trajectory of being that close to something like Saturn it gets torn to shreds like what's happening to the moon right now
So even these fragments I think are getting torn into even smaller fragments
So every time they get hit they get ripped apart again, which is creating
I believe a ring or at least it will create a ring here comes the moon again
Oh, it's beautiful. Oh, yeah more fragments
All right. So let's just let this run for a good while I'm gonna go up to 10 hours a second
It's just gonna run unless the moon
slams into the earth
Which I don't think actually it's gonna do I think it's gonna be a super
Elliptical orbit and every time it passes by more and more fragments are gonna be torn up
each of the fragments getting smaller and smaller it's like being run through a
Blender and some of the fragments aren't coming back. Like obviously those guys ain't coming back
But the ones that do get caught in here, they just keep spiraling over and over again. That's so cool
This is not what I expected to happen. Oh
They're coming back
The fragments are coming back. Oh
Look at you guys. Oh, look at you guys are any of these guys coming back. Nope. Those guys are outie
The moon has lost a lot of its mass
The moon has lost almost three powers of ten of its mass just from being shredded in the Earth's gravity
I'm not a hundred percent sure, but I think the moon actually might be getting closer and closer to this thing
Whoa, that one tore up into a bunch. I wonder if there's something I can do to make the Earth's atmosphere
Larger. Oh, that's so cool
You can make green. Could we?
could we try to simulate the
terraforming of a planet like
could we terraform Mars Oh
That'd be nuts
Okay, that's next on my list. That's next on my list. Oh, that's so cool. Okay. So, but anyway, let's try to
Make more atmosphere. Let's say the atmosphere is going to be larger. It is now one magnitude larger, which I think
should cause some of these things to rub and
Therefore slow down. Okay, so I'm gonna I'm gonna put the kibosh on this I'm gonna raise the
Let's go back to one. I'm gonna raise the mass to no not one hundred and twenty twenty whoa, whoa
Whoa, whoa. Whoa. Okay. Yeah Wow. Oh wow. That is that is causing a
Great deal of destruction. I
I'm sorry. Oh boy. Yeah. Wha Oh
Oh boy, that's that's bad. Okay, well
I have a funka-
Ooo I have a funkalicious feeling
That the moon's gonna have something to say about this real soon and by real soon
I mean right about now slow slow slow slow slow down. There we go. Alright Moony
Sorry, it had to be like this. But you know how it be you know how it be bub. Oh and before we hit
Let's make you Massier
Just just cuz you know, you gotta be what you once was you can't be what you are
You're you're just a shrimpy boy now. You got to be a big beefy boy, you know what I mean?
I think the moon was bigger than that. I'm pretty sure alright Moony
There you go. Now that's more like a moon
Maybe even the moon was a bit bigger I think. Oh, yeah. No, it's it's that's about the size of the moon
Alright now you may impact
Oh boy yeah we done yeah we done yeah we all done yeah we done oh my oh
Wow, you know what this is gonna do is this gonna form another moon
That's what this is gonna coalesce into I bet
That's gonna form another moon. Oh, no wait. It's gonna come crashing back down on earth
Ohhh never mind
Oh my god
Never mind it's just gonna cause a horrible ring of destruction. Is that is that what's left of the moon?
Wait, what is what is that? That is a very
That is a very round
formation
What the heck? Oh my god. Oh my god it did
It formed another moon
This one is 21 times the mass of the moon, but this is not the original moon
They hit this is fragments that coalesced into this super super hot ball of
liquid rock and while the earth is just
Burning alive. Oh my god. It is it is just a fire wave of destruction. It is still going
Oh my god, these are probably tidal waves of lava kilometres high
Huh oh the earth is like a perfectly. Oh my god
That is beautiful and horrible
Yeah, and there's more still crashing into it right now but this guy is gonna go right back into it
Never mind I thought  I thought that was gonna be a moon. No it- she's Oh
Actually, I mean what if I drop the weight of the earth just just a bit
Let's make it 15
Let's make it 15. Yeah, let's actually let's make it let's make it down to 10. Let's make it 10 see how that does
See now the orbits a little bit bigger
The earth is still getting bombarded and that's okay, but this is now not going to impact again
So let's crank up the time while this is, you know, this is currently dying
But you know it is what it is. But the earth you know, it sang its swan song. It's it's pretty much donezo
So why not? Why not go a little faster? All right
So all- as of this point all life has been wiped off don't think that just cuz this sections not on fire doesn't mean that
Everything's dead there because everything is very dead. They're
extremely dead
Very dead all oceans boiled off. Everything is just gone. The mantle is ruptured
so the entire like the entire surfaces is going to be completely destabilized and
All the tectonic plates look right now. The the water is boiling off, which is such a cool feature
I didn't know that they could actually do that
But the water is boiling off and the water is now all vapor all greenery is gone
There's nothing left but ash and dust and there's another piece. No, that's the same piece. Okay?
Now this is the new moon. This is old Earth
That's new moon and there you have it
These fragments are still gonna be falling back down. We are very dead. But what we got fair trade
Is a new moon
Let's go up to one hour a second. Okay? Oh, that is just that is just beautiful
That is just beautiful. I don't think we just got a moon
I think we got a I think we got like a belt. Whoa. Look at this guy. Oh, he's beefy
Oh, that's a beefy piece. Oh, that is a big piece. Yep
Oh the earth is just going to be unbelievably hot molten lava surface for like
For like
For years. I mean we'll figure out how many years Oh fragments coming in
Yeah, but this is our new moon. Can I rename it?
name new moon
There we go
This is so cool. That's so cool. That's so cool. I mean everyone's dead but it's so cool
Well, the fragments are starting to cool down. So they're gonna lose some of their glow some things are still impacting
But yeah, it's gonna be like this for a long time. So let's go ahead let's go up to ten
Let's go up to as fast as it'll go. Let's get some speed out of this, right the earth is starting to cool
On one side anyway, it's still really hot. Like really really really hot. But as it cools OH
Some pieces of the new moon are being pulled into the earth, which is not gonna do well for it
I wonder if it'll ever like
Get out of the lopsided orbit
Let's reduce the mass of the earth back down to a little bit more reasonable levels and let's make the moon, you know
Let's make it almost equally a difference. Okay. So new moon. Where is New Moon going?
So New Moon's orbits still little lopsided but it's the least it's going around the earth
The Earth is still extremely hot way too hot to have any water yet
But weirdly enough I think this is snow in some weird ecological parts of this there is snow
I don't know where the lights coming from, but
Yeah
Still there?
That's cool
How's the new moon doing? New moon's cooling down. Oh, it looks more like just a rock. Well, that's that's not fair. That's not fair
I thought it'd be looks more spherical. Oh
Come on now
I'll smooth out over a few millennia. It's only been 158 days according to the simulation. Well shit. That's not long at all. All right
What is the auto orbit do well, there we go. Ooh
Orbit, well, that's nice
Now its orbiting
Nice. Oh
Cool. Okay. All right that situation is done. Well, that's that's one way to kill the earth
I could always do like like different examples of that
Okay, but what I'm gonna do now is something a little bit different instead of having the moon pull itself into the earth
I'm gonna pull the earth into the moon. We're gonna make this bad boy
We're gonna make this bad boy. Literally a hundred moons big
Let's make it even bigger. Let's make it even bigger. It's only one of earth. Let's make it let's make it a hundred earths
Who's a big boy
Who's a big boy?
Who's who's a big boy?
Let's make it even bigger. Let's make this bad boy a thousand earths. Whoa
Who's a big boy Oh thats a oh thats a moon all right. Okay, so
Whoof. All right. So this is what I like to call the super moon, you know
You may have heard of a super moon in terms of
You know
In terms of like it's pretty big tonight
Now this one it's uh, it's um, yeah, it's uh, it's gonna kill us all so let's see that in slow motion
So what's gonna happen? The earth is pretty much making a straight beeline towards the moon
Guys it is that's not even close
that's not even close to an elliptical that is straight into the moon. Okay. So this is a nightmare scenario
imagine there was some crazy scientists that found a way to increase both the size and the mass of the moon cause you know
They don't have to necessarily be the same thing, but little ol' earth
Everyone you know and love is gonna uh oh
BOOM ohhh my god
i should've slowed time down a bit
Geez that was uh
Impactful oh, oh now it's your turn moon and now you get burnt to a crisp
But you know, it's okay the moon is now two-
The moon is now three times the size of Jupiter
And and she's a-burnin', oh she's a-burning bright. Alright, let's speed her up. Okay. There we go BLAP. All right, cool
well, that is um
Not good
It's a firestorm, but that's okay
Alright, but while we're at this, oh, maybe we could maybe we could terraform this bad boy while we're at this
She's real hot
7700 degrees that's real hot, but
I don't think we're gonna be able to terraform this. Oh, wow. That's hot. Wait. Why- Are you getting hotter? What the hell?
Wait what's happening?
The moon's shrinking
the moon
The moon is collapsing in on itself. Oh, oh
Oh, it's gonna start fusion eventually. Oh my god, what's gonna happen when it hits that point?
What's gonna happen, I mean right now it's not it's not really a star
It's it's just it's a very very very like dense planet
That doesn't mean that it's not going to. the density is falling off, but that doesn't mean that it's- it's still going up
That's crazy. Okay, let's speed it up just a little bit woah
She is bright, I love this I love this so much. I don't know if she's gonna make a diffusion
Density- I don't know what the density- okay density is now falling off pretty good
Okay, is that because I increased the gravity did the gravity actually increase?
Is that just me being crazy? What I'm going to do is I'm gonna add things to this until it gets
You know
The right thing. How big is Jupiter if I get- Jupiter is technically bigger than this
But this is three times the mass of Jupiter. I mean that I think that's what makes it like fascinating. Okay?
Let's add
Let's add some close orbit earths. Okay well never mind then
Too close too close.
Oh boy, oh, well, that's that's fun
Okay, we got some earths ah
Now what I intended to do
Humanity died a long time ago, but I think I think this is just overkill at this point
Alright, I'm gonna jump the mass of this to four to swallow these up
Swallow. Oh
Yeah, okay. So the mass is actually- the density is actually decreasing, which is fascinating
That's weird. The density is decreasing probably as it cools. Ah
Weird it's gonna settle into some kind of bizarre like it's gonna actually cool down
The surface gravity is immense, but it's cooling down
So I went off on a weird tangent
I I was I know I'm trying to destroy the earth here
But just I went of on a tangent because I couldn't help it. This is so cool. Okay, so she's cooling down pretty good
But that's not what I want. She's burnt
She's a little toasty a little toasted a little little burnt on the edges. Let's make this five. Let's go five
Whoo, not. What did I just do it turned into it? How did you do 500 I said five
Okay, the density just the density went nuts, I don't know what happened
Okay. I wanted to go five but it went to
500 for some reason okay, so she's not she's not done. She ain't done yet, but
She's doing pretty good, but I'm not done yet
tools
material ah
Hydrogen, cool.
I don't know what this is doing for the moon but you know shooting hydrogen at it
What the hell?
Oh, she just turned into a gas giant what the hell
Well, that's so weird, oh never mind yo she back there she is
The moon is now a beautiful blue gas giant with cloud- You can see oh
That's so nice
I love that so much
That's so nice. Let's get some water in there
Okay, that might have been enough. Ooh, it is getting toasty
okay
The density is definitely going up oo it's getting hot. Oh
oh it's getting hot. Oh, it's getting hot and it's getting toasty
Oh
She's heating up good
I love the bands just the like bands are those simulated are those simulated bands based on like the density of it like
On what it'd actually be because it's these really harsh spirals of heat. So cool.
It just it just went woah
She just went solar oh
She just went solar and then suddenly the moon is now a star oh
And you can ride along the surface of it, oh my god
That's real cool. Okay. Anyway alright enough of that I just got distracted I'm trying to blow up earth
I'm trying to blow up earth. climate simulation ooh
Wait climate simulation. What would that do?
What no way
What I didn't know it could do that what the hell
That's so cool. So let's imagine
Just for a bit. I'm going to add
This is another way that we can destroy the world. We're gonna add just too gosh-darn much. Let's not make it earths. Let's just do
let's do uh
Kilograms, no, not that much. Let's do a thousand kilograms. There we go. It's going we're going at a lovely
Let's go one day a second. You know, let's add us some carbon dioxide
Okay, this is gonna do next to nothing to the earth. So let's
Try to at least make it some kind of considerable.
The earth is- woah okay. Well that all right. There you go. The earth just got fucked
The earth just got yeah, okay and the earth destroyed checkbox done there. I think the UH the
what threw me off there was just like
Yeah, what threw me off was everything another big fear. Is that for some reason somehow someway
We create a black hole on earth. Now not just any black hole because these are big black holes
What I want is I want a black hole that is tiny a tiny itty bitty black hole
So let's pause this and imagine just imagine that in the centre of the earth
Was a black hole
Now the black hole is there I might actually reduce the mass of this black hole to
0.01 the mass of the Sun which is still considerable. It's about ten Jupiters actually, let's even make that smaller
Let's make that 0.1 Jupiters. It's a small black hole but a black hole it still is. Even smaller than that
Let's go ten Earths
Tiny black hole by comparison, but we make it somehow in the center of our earth is a black hole
So let's reduce this down to the seconds. I'm gonna go one second at a time and see what nevermind it's gone
Okay. Jeez.
I don't think that's how it'd go but alright. Whoa, that's cool. Alright, wait back up a second back up a second
Hang on, I don't think that's what would happen. But you know hang on let's just- hang on. Alright, so let's try this again
We're gonna go one minute per second. We're gonna add a black hole right here
Black hole Sun won't you come wash away the pain it's gonna be the size of Earth
What happens as you can see not very much oh
Wait, we got something. What is this?
What was that? I don't know what that is. What is that? What are these? What are all these dots what is happening?
Oh, oh, oh
The the water is getting pulled off of the earth. Is that what is that? What that is? Oh
Oh, oh, oh, she's oh she's she's a goner
Oh, oh, she's a she's a goner all the water just got ripped off of the earth
Every drop of it probably the atmosphere too surface temp is now 2,000 degrees just from that pass
Pieces of the earth huge pieces. This is a- This is an
Enormous enormous about point about 2% the size of the moon.
Pieces of the earth 2% the size of the Moon are being ripped
Straight out of africa by a black hole the size of one earth and then this is going to go into the earth
Right about there. I speed it up a bit and she's oh it's impacting back down
Yep, this black hole did
Did quite a number?
On ye old earth here hoo
hoo
Hoo Nelly. Oh, well there she goes there she goes
There she goes the second pass turns out to be much much much more destructive. Oh ma
Oh mama Jambo the earth don't look so good there the earth
Yeah that earth. Um
Yeah, that's uh Wow Oh, oh my oh
Holy shit
okay, so word to the wise
Don't make black holes
Oh them's bad news them's just bad news all around.
Oh my computer is struggling lesson learned don't uh, don't do that. Oh, that's a pretty sight though
Oh, look at this the echoing shock waves just on the earth. That's crashing in there. That's donezo.
Oh my god, that's so cool. Alright, so that's one way
Now what else I'm gonna do. Let's load back up. Ye olde earth again this poor earth. I'm subjecting it to so much horrors
Alright, so what am I do is I'm gonna turn this moon into a black hole in procedural steps
We're gonna go I'm not gonna mess with its mass at all. I'm gonna mess with its density. It's uh,
Let's say it's calculated radius
That's gonna be on I'm gonna make its density now
100 grams per centim- centimeter squared so it's now much more dense, right? He's a dense ball
He's the dense ball, but it's still not so bad. Alright, let's go a thousand bonk
She's tinier she's much smaller. She's much smaller, but not too bad. Okay, let's go ten thousand. All right tinier
She's getting teensy tiny now now see the orbit will not be changed in any way cuz it's still the same mass
Same exact mass. So the orbits not gonna go any differently, but if we keep cranking her down, not the earth. No thank you
Keep cranking her down. Let's go another one
boink again
Blonk and
Tinsy tinier very very tiny
Super tiny very dense. Very dense. Okay, let's go one more
Then
very dense
Very very dense. Okay, let's go even tinier
Dense. Oh, she's so dense moon is now tiny tiny
the moon is 56 centimeters across its surface gravity is 1.56 times 10 to the 13th meter per second
Which technically should be faster than the speed of light very very faster
So this should have turned into a black hole, but it hasn't for some reason. So let's go even further
Okay, where's the moon? There's the moon. Okay. There we go. The moon has now disappeared it is 0.026
Let's crank it back down a bit
So if this simulation was correct it this should be a black hole it is basically the equivalent of a black hole
It is super dense. It should not exist that way and
Yeah, it's uh
That's pretty crazy. Okay. This is now 5.6 millimeters
This is the size of a bullet but same exact orbit same exact orbit
Because nothing's changed about the mass of it. Now what would happen if I did change the mass of it?
Right. So it's radius. I'm gonna lock it. I'm gonna lock the radius lock that radius off imma change that mass
There we go, it is now become a black hole because I changed the mass of it and I wasn't supposed to do that
But it's now a black hole
just sucked in all
All the matter down to a singularity light can't even escape it but it's a black hole now
So does that mean it changed anything about?
the orbit from the earth
Apparently yes, which isn't necessarily supposed to be true. That's not necessarily supposed to be how that happens
Not 100% sure why cause even if it was a black hole, it shouldn't be any different. You know what I mean?
Oh, but I did increase the mass of it that that's what happened. Okay, so what I'm doing now is
I've created a new galaxy basically
there we are
Okay, so I just spawned a new galaxy on top of Earth pretty much on top of it's not right there
But this one's got some dark matter. So that's not gonna go well
Basically dark matter who honestly knows what it is. No one knows what it is
No one knows what it does, but there's also a supermassive black hole in the center right here
So that is gonna do a number on earthy boy right here. So let's just see
Where she's going? Oh, she's going dead into the okay. Well, that's not good
Well, let's see what happens, huh as hilarious as it is to have this moon like that. I'm gonna just
Okay, I'm gonna think of a stop it for a moment. Just cuz very hard to keep this. Uh, this this idea going
Okay, just gonna get rid of the moon for now. Sorry moon. You outie. Oh and
We off we off like a rocket. Apparently, we're going three thousand years a second.
We we're going three thousand years a second. Yes but that takes a real long time still to get to the supermassive black hole, but we're going.
Alright, so just imagine everyone is able to live long enough to panic for over a hundred thousand years now as we journey to
The center of this supermassive black hole there. We've made it almost no distance. Alright, we need to jump it up a little bit
We're gonna go
we're gonna go a hundred thousand years a second and
We are just barely making progress at a hundred thousand years per second.
We are just starting to make some progress
Let's make that five hundred thousand years per second
Okay, we're very close to our destination apparently we're near some dark matter
I don't know where the black hole is but uh
You know, I have a funny feeling it's real close
Okay, I think I missed it. Where the hell did the
Where'd the supermassive black hole go
You know the supermassive black hole that I was looking at it we passed it. We somehow overshot it
the supermassive black hole We were off
Cigar
cigar
Oh cigar is the name of the galaxy. Okay. Alright, that's funny. Alright, so we made it guys. Good job. Everybody. Be happy. Oh
Shit, never mind. We are an ice ball. We are a ball of ice where there is no life. Not even it but there is still life
We are some persistent sons of bitches aren't we yeah, we're tenacious
Alright, but anyway that's that's that apparently the next way that we're all gonna die is by making the Sun go supernova
Now technically, I think the Sun is supposed to go supernova
But I don't think that's supposed to be going anytime soon. But you know, let's just say
That this bad boy, he's gonna go kaboomy real hard
Gravity
Wait was gravity not on
Why was gravity not on what since when was gravity not on?
When was gravity not on Oh here we are explode we're gonna make this bad boy explode
We're gonna explode you get ready for explody it let's slow it down to by the hour and let's explode
Uh, yeah, let's explode you bang. Ok, supernova. It has begun
We're going by the let's go by the minute actually 1 minute per second alright go
And we're kabooming and we're kabooming and we can see the view from Earth as a spectacular explosion. Ooh
It's real pretty as it comes to destroy all of your money
And as the blast gets closer and closer, we're already heating up more and more
So, you know that's something to look forward to
Ok, if we watch very closely it looks like a big old eyeball
But instead of an eyeball, it's red hot death
Exploding towards us very quickly
The oceans have started to boil away, which is always a good sign. The supernova has almost engulfed us
It is very very scary
okay, we are just crossing the
Threshold of the supernova. We are now 300. We're now 400 degrees Celsius surface temperature
There's still some ocean left, which is very shocking to be perfectly honest surface temperatures approaching 700 degrees
Hell, yeah, it's like an oven in here even hotter than it was before in Africa
But now it's really a lot. We didn't even know there was a chain like that. That's cool
Well, let's step it up a bit. We're gonna go 10 minutes
Earth is 2,000 degrees. I feel like- 3000. Oh God. Okay. It's roasting
alright we are starting to become incinerated by the expanding supernova the supernova it has like
Now officially we're I think we could definitely be considered dead we are 9,000 degrees. We are 10,000 degrees
We are all continents have lost all shape or form. They are very oh
The earth is contracting
oddly enough it-
She's getting smaller. I guess by the temperature is like causing it to be more dense. Oh
She's oh no, I think she's no she's just bleeding off. All of its mass is literally exploding off of it
Oh, that's what's happening
Okay, the earth is shrinking because it is losing everything that it once was and it is now going going going going going going
And
She's gone
She gone baby, how's Mars doing? How's Mars bars doing? Oh, not any better. She's roasting
I just got over here to see Mars
Uh go off into the sunset and goodbye Mars
And the supernova has claimed us all we are all dead and we will never ever live again because we're dead
Fun times what is happening here? I don't feel like this is a good thing
Whatever is happening here, and I'm not sure what happened here. But whatever's happening here. Oh
Yeah, that's that's not good
Yeah, that's okay. We're each in line to go into Jupiter even Oh Oh God
Oh, no, I came at a bad time
shabooski, ashabooski shaboo-woah. Okay, that's one way for earth to die
I don't know who put us like this, but that's definitely a way for earth to die
And the winner is Jupiter
All right
There you have it not what I was hoping for but that happened. All right
So now that we've killed the earth over and over again, let's do something else. Let's do something a little more fun
I want to try to terraform Mars
Okay. So here's how we're gonna do. This Mars is a nice planet. It's not quite as big as Earth
It doesn't have anywhere near the atmosphere
And as far as we know it doesn't have an iron core, but that doesn't mean that it can't sustain life at some point
It's got not much of an atmosphere, but it's got some of an atmosphere. It's got all the basic building blocks of life
It just doesn't necessarily have what it needs to keep life. That's the thing iron silicate water and hydrogen
Okay, let's make it more water. Let's make just a little more water
Let's make it make it like that much water. So we got water there, but it's mostly ice right now
So what we need to do is we need to give it more iron as well
Let's give it more iron one more power of 10 more iron
There we go now it has an iron core
All right, we're gonna turn climate on just to give this simulation some oomph, huh? So that is a start
but in order to do this more we're going to need to
Figure out a way to get this thing a magnetosphere
Now apparently there is a way to create a magnetosphere, but I'm not 100% sure how to do it
So I've got it an iron core, but I don't know if that's gonna do anything to the magnetosphere and in fact
We've lost a lot of similarity to
To earth, but that's okay. We had a chance of life before but it's all gone now, but that's fine
Don't worry about that because we're gonna change this up for the better. What we need to do is we need to add
Some carbon dioxide because what it doesn't have what it doesn't have in anyway
Is an atmosphere it needs an atmosphere. It's got no atmosphere right now, very none atmosphere
In fact, I think I accidentally destroyed all the atmosphere and that's why I can't do anything right now, but I'm gonna add some
Atmosphere to it. In fact, I'm just gonna add some right here. Let's add
a hundred thousand kilograms of atmosphere that's not gonna do a whole lot
Nope apparently we're not gonna add a hundred thousand kilograms of atmosphere
Maybe I just need to add carbon dioxide. Okay, we're gonna add carbon dioxide
We're gonna add a hundred thousand carbon- kilograms of carbon dioxide at a time actually
I'm going to restart this. Okay, we're gonna start again. Oh, let's go one hour at a time. All right. There we go
That's a nice planet. That's real nice right there. That's a real nice planet
So what we got here is we got a little problem. It doesn't have nearly as much
Anything that we need and we do need it to have things. So let's turn on the climate. Let's turn that on
Let's turn on
The visualization of the magnetosphere which we don't have not yet anyway
and let's change the composition to a little more iron and then
There's water in there. There is water in there. Let me just raise it up just a bit more. There we go
That's just enough water
We're not gonna mess with the hydrogen because apparently that just blows up the atmosphere instantaneously
and we're not gonna do that yet. We have other things that we're going to do
It will not just get a magnetosphere as far as I know but life likelihood is now a little bit higher
Yeah. Oh, that's pretty good. So we need to give it more atmosphere. So how do we do that?
So the temperature is going to be trending upwards what this is gonna need is is gonna need a lot more atmosphere
than say other things have so let me see if adding carbon dioxide is just going to ruin this
I also got to remember that a hundred thousand kilograms of anything is not a lot when it comes to
The entire planet so let's add even more carbon dioxide
There we go
Okay, I gave it a magnetosphere cool. Well, that's the first thing that we needed
We definitely needed that so increasing chance of life has gone up a little bit
Alright, so now we got to kick it up a notch
We got we got kind of the basic stuff
but we got an atmosphere a little bit not not a lot of it and I mean we could have more atmosphere obviously
and lets make a little more atmosphere
Here we go. Oh shit. The greenhouse effect is real high on that. That's probably too high
What is let me let me compared to earth. What is what is Earth's greenhouse effect on all that stuff? Ah
Okay good
Okay, there we go. I think that's just about right. Alright, so we're getting better. We've got definitely a denser atmosphere
Let's show that turn off the magnetosphere
the surface temperature is
Not great, but we can improve it by actually, uh, and this may sound counterintuitive
But we can improve it by throwing things at the planet. So we're gonna just throw a random asteroid
Never mind, that was faster than I thought. Okay
Didn't think that was gonna be like that
Let's keep this down to the minute. Shall we?
Okay random asteroid Chuck that bad boy over there
Boom
All right, so I'm gonna let that cook for a bit we're gonna let that cook toss it in the oven for a few days
And she's gonna really think about that one and we're still going cold, why are we going cold I
Was it cuz we're going farther away from the Sun? Okay, so we're gonna need what is what is the surface pressure?
Around 98.2. Okay, so we need to crank up the surface pressure of of mars four
Boom one atmosphere on the dot at 1.01 that's better
So now we're gonna have a much more pronounced greenhouse effect
We're gonna be able to keep our temperature relatively good and then we can heat this bad boy up
Excuse all the pockmarks had some bad acne, you know
let's just try a small moon
There we go
Surface temperature is higher
BAM no one said this was easy. Okay, I'm resetting. Whoa. That is too much water. Okay
That's way too much water. All right, let's tone down the water there gents tone down the water. Whoa on the water
Ease up on the water. I don't know what that's all about, but that's happening
Okay, we've got the beginnings of clouds just the beginnings
So what I'm going to do is I'm gonna increase the surface temperature to ten degrees Celsius
that is a big shift from what it once was and
It's got a little bit of an atmosphere to keep that but that doesn't mean that it's gonna stay that way
I wish I took out the big ass scars and stuff, but we're gonna ignore that. I didn't actually need to do that
But we are going to pretend like it was necessary. All right, and would you look at that? We've got some clouds forming
So it's still cold
but it should be able to keep its temperature once it's able to start melting and
And like growing some clouds clouds are
Reflective and stuff and they can keep it cool. But also like the the engine of
water changing it states can be
Self-sustaining in a way, so hopefully that's going to help it in the long run. Okay. Now I'm going to increase its mass
now this may ruin everything else, but I'm just gonna increase its mass by
About double I'm gonna double its mass
Roughly so in doing that it changes up a lot of things about it
Suddenly the gravity is more intense is able to hold its atmosphere a little bit better. You know what I mean?
so if it's able to hold its atmosphere better, it'll lose less to the
surrounding space it'll radiate out less the main problem with with Mars is that it doesn't
Necessarily get that much heat from the Sun. You know what I mean?
So we're almost where we need to be
The only problem now is it's not able to hold its temperature now in order to get it to hold its temperature
I'm hoping that adding carbon dioxide will be able to do such a feat. If not
Well, then we've got more of a problem, but I think this should
Be able to help it along that's increasing its mass incredibly
I raised it's mass to earth levels, which I don't know good or bad. I don't know seems to be okay
Why is the greenhouse effect going down if I had carbon dioxide that's dumb. Oh, that's dumb
Huh, okay. Well, no god damn it
Okay, and that is about as good as I can get it I think I've g- why are we looking over there
Don't look over there
You're gonna reveal my secret so I couldn't get it to have the right
Reflectivity if it was too far away from the Sun so I had to move it closer
basically
It's between Earth and Venus now not really practical
But then again nothing else I was doing it was exactly practical like raising the mass of the entire planet, but that's about it
So I made life. And anyway, I'm gonna blow it up because I can't stand to even think about that. So kaboom
Ah, oh, wow. You were gone fast. I was thinking that there was gonna be like a little more time
But anyway earth, let's look at earth blow up to say goodbye here. So this has been universe sandbox
I've been playing around like way longer than I thought I would
I've just been having a crazy amount of fun
Thank you everybody so much for watching really do appreciate you guys being here and just thanks so much for watching. I uh
Yeah, I just love space so much. Whoa there she goes. Uh oh, so thank you everybody so much for watching
I know I've said that like 15 times now
But just thank you. If you got any other games you want me to play please write them down in the comments below
Let me know what you thinking if you got other ways that you want to blow up earth
Let me know down in the comments as well
And if you want to hit the join button and help support this channel and help me make cool stuff
The links right down there. Thanks again everybody so much for watching one more time
And as always I will see you in the next video
Bye bye what happen if you blew up a black hole? Oh
Whoa
What the
I don't even know what happened there what happened
Okay, it gone I guess
(Welp, Mark broke the game... I think.)
(Subscribe to Markiplier for more amazing content)
(Bye!)